November 2004 440 miles above India
NASA's Terra satellite photographs a
perfectly circular lake in an otherwise
flat featureless plateau visitors to the
lake encounter strange magnetic forces
interfering with electrical equipment
and sending compasses haywire
it's weird it's not normal water it can
create magnetic disturbances the image
comes from the bull Donna district in
the state of Maharashtra western India
the 4000 foot wide perfectly circular
Lake poses a twin puzzle for scientists
along with the weird electromagnetic
anomaly the lake itself doesn't fit the
local geology lunar Lake has higher
magnetic readings in the surrounding
area it's definitely unique in this
terrain it's it's kind of bizarre
geologists consider whether the lakes
weird magnetic properties could be
extraterrestrial in origin from the
impact of a large meteorite objects that
come from space are generally more
magnetic than the materials that they
strike on the terrestrial as the typical
raised rim it's extremely round it looks
like a meteorite impact crater
if a meteor created the lake there
should still be evidence of the impact
we would expect to see ejecta blanket
stuff that's been blown out of the hole
you would expect to find and mineral
structure of the materials has
drastically changed by the high
temperatures associated with that impact
and that's exactly what local geologists
have found surrounding the crater are
all kinds of minerals and rock fragments
that are produced when high-pressure
high-temperature metamorphism occurs so
the impactor hits and rock is melted and
brought to high pressure and we see
unusual minerals like masculinity
maskull a knight is a glassy looking
rock created by the kind of high
pressure shockwaves you get from
meteorite impacts it looks like a
smoking gun
not only do we find an ejecta blanket
around the lonar crater but also we find
in the interior of the crater ground up
Rock pulverized rock that's been melted
and has collapsed back into the crater
attempts to date the meteorite strike
have been only partially successful but
it could have been as recent as 50,000
years ago
you